foreign
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and
we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones in
House of the Dragon update video in this
video I want to show you a new article
that was written about one of the fan
favorites from House of the dragon's
first season as you can see from the
headline one of House of the dragon's
main actors says they are done with
fantasy they're not only saying they are
done filming the first season either we
already know that what they're actually
saying is they no longer want to work on
any more fantasy shows or films ever
again I must say I was a little shocked
when I read this headline because they
did such an amazing job on House of the
Dragon like I said they are one of the
fan favorites from the first season in a
show that already has a number of
incredible actors in their lineup now
before we do get into everything else
that was said I have to let all of you
know about this amazing new offer I'd
like to thank the sponsor of today's
video Ridge wallet say goodbye to your
bulky old wallet and jump into the 21st
century with the Reds quality and key
case this Sleek wallet holds up to 12
cards plus there's still room for cash
there are over 30 colors and styles to
choose from including carbon fiber and
my favorite the burnt titanium the
wallets are made with RFID blocking
technology that protects you from
digital pickpocketers and the durable
material means that each wallet comes
with a lifetime warranty plus the ridge
team is so confident that you'll like it
they'll let you test drive it for 45
days you can send it back for a full
refund if you don't love it but I know
you will the wallets have over 50 000
five-star reviews I love the way this
wallet fits in my pocket and I know you
will too the key case is a simple and
convenient fix to Bulky keychains it
holds all of your keys in place quietly
this key case has really been a game
changer for me I no longer have to carry
two sets of keys and the best part about
it for me is that it hooks right onto
your belt loop or your lanyard get the
best offer on your wallet and key case
with my link ridge.com talking Thrones
and right now you can save 40 through
December 22nd thanks again to Ridge
wallet for partnering with me on today's
video alright now let's let's jump into
this new article so we can all see what
this actor had to say as you all know
House of the dragon's first season was a
massive success and many of its unknown
actors are now famous all over the realm
however one of them had to say they are
done with fantasy one of the younger
members who also garnered a lot of
attention from House of the Dragon was
Australian actress Millie Alcock better
known as the younger version of rhaenyra
Targaryen after filming the Epic first
season of House of the Dragon Millie
went back to her native Australia to
film the second season of a show known
as upright which is drastically smaller
than what she's done in the Game of
Thrones Universe Millie goes on to
discuss how she now wants to work in
different genres of film during her
interview with the herald son she said I
don't want to do fantasy anymore I don't
want to do anything like that I have
done it and I don't need to do it again
I would rather work less and do work
that I really enjoy when you sign on to
work on something you have to get ready
to discuss it for about six months or a
year of your life so you want to make
sure you really adore it and I'm waiting
for something that comes along and
surprises me now this makes me wonder if
something negative happened on set was
there something that happened that's
making her want to walk away from
fantasy maybe all of her work on House
of the Dragon has her exhausted as one
of the lead actors and arguably the
biggest and most successful show of the
year the rising Aussie star was front
and center during its extensive media
campaign with her face splashed all over
Billboards and buses around the world as
well as magazines and online ads Millie
says I didn't actually ever see any
Billboards which I thought was funny but
it's weird I'm so sick of my face I am
so sick of it as an actor you want to
escape yourself but now her face is
everywhere and she's loved by millions
of fans all over the realm I know I'm
not the only one who would love to see
her in another fantasy show or film I
also do understand why she would want to
work on something else that way she
doesn't get stuck in fantasy for the
rest of her life as we all know this
does happen to a lot of actors as soon
as they're in something massive that
everyone knows them for it's hard for
anyone else to see them doing something
else especially when you're really good
at it like Millie was during House of
the dragon's first season what I am
shocked by though is how it sounds like
she wouldn't even consider working in
fantasy again I mean what if Amazon
reached out to her because they wanted
her to work on the second season of The
Lord of the Rings show or if Netflix
wanted her for one of their major
fantasy shows I wonder if she would
still be able to walk away from
something like that then again maybe she
doesn't want to be that famous I know I
certainly wouldn't want my face all over
everything everywhere I go Millie also
says she's still trying to find her new
normal after House of the Dragon but she
knows the global success it has given
her means that her life will never be
the same again but there's also this
element of this won't be here forever
and it will eventually die down her
friends and family have also helped her
keep her head firmly on her shoulders
and her feet on the ground I know I'm
not all that she says with a laugh and
you just can't buy into it I guess so I
haven't been believing it I am in a bit
of denial and while she wasn't a fan of
watching her own episodes of House of
the Dragon she did watch the rest of the
season with Fascination as Emma drc's
Ranier went head to head against Olivia
Cook's Alison Hightower after the death
of viserys to set up the second season
IMO and Rainier aside she said I think
everyone is so Sensational in it em and
Liv are amazing and Patty considine it
seems now it's only the world is
figuring out how incredible he is and
how he has been since before I was born
Millie also says that the most valuable
lesson she learned from working with
veteran actors of the caliber of Mr
considine Matt Smith and Rhys hyphens is
how to treat everyone on set and I don't
just mean don't be a dick obviously she
says I mean more the way the older and
more established actors would approach
their work to the creative team and the
other actors in the room they were
really open to ideas and criticism but
also to know when to fight for a choice
that they made knowing when to be bold
and when to be brave and one to say no
this is what I think it's easy as a
young actor and especially a young woman
to always say yes and not know when to
fight or when to have a voice she's also
grateful for the freedom the role has
given her in terms of what she will do
next she said she doesn't have anything
lined up right now but she's adamant
that whatever it is will not involve
dragons or magic well there you have it
ladies and gentlemen House of the
dragon's first season might be the one
and only time we will ever see the great
Millie allcock work with fantasy I guess
if it's the only thing she does in this
genre she will be walking away with one
hell of a batting average she might not
have been in that many episodes of this
series but she certainly made a name for
herself while she was here let me know
what all of you think down below as
always I want to thank all of you for
watching this video I hope all of you
have a great day I will see you again
very soon bye
foreign
[Music]
[Music]